[Music]
if you ain't got more heart than me
if you ain't been working harder than me
if you ain't sacrifice more than me
I'ma destroy you and I'm not retreating
I'm not running
happiness comes from progress
unhappiness comes from regress and I
have learned this that the time between
the tides of your life the falling tide
of your life looks like you're losing
everything get your line in the water
because that's the most fertile period
of your life you must try new things you
must be fully Alive you must try
everything you possibly can to wake up
each day and to live that day full of
possibility not to nurse your wounds not
to waste your time not to try to do
things that you used to do to be fully
Alive is to be alive to the new set of
experiences that's that's coming across
the transom
that's super important because during
this time of luminality you need to
understand your own values what you
value what you think is proper and
correct and moral and if you know what
that is and can articulate it and live
according to that you will be happy I
think we're an involved enough species
to say no there is a right and wrong
there's a better path and and a not so
good path there is a transcend itself at
least to chase a better self a
projection I think is fair to project
and believe in a delayed gratification
that no I want my life to have some
escalation
yeah I know it's going to have its downs
but I want to have at the end at least
have a small ramp or what the hell are
we doing here or what is evolution
we have to have started Mitty
more not judging admitting
let's get rid of the lies
process of elimination first before we
get on with playing offense let's admit
the lies that we tell ourselves let's
admit the lies that we believe that the
world tells us let's admit the ones that
we keep under our vests for our own
convenience because they've been getting
away with them and they kind of been
let's just admit that don't judge it I'm
not saying so I can lay the hammer on
you and go you see you son of I'm not
saying that and then I'm not and I don't
think any of us should be doing that to
ourself right now so there's a bit of
amnesty and just admit it don't just
let's admit the lies that we tell we
believe in the Kool-Aid we know we're
drinking the candy we know we're eating
but we like to call it broccoli because
hey it gives us some identity and some
sense of purpose let's clean the Slate
there first
and then
I think we need to Define what we want
more of the world tells us every day
it's a it's more it's quantifiable only
there's a lane there's a there's 360
Degrees that lane that is vertical is
packed with traffic everybody once on
that lane we're being told retail
therapy success more money it's the only
way to win this life got no problem with
any of that but there's 359 other lanes
in the degrees of 360. that have a lot
less traffic on them that also have a
lot more qualitative value to them so
where can we scale wider where can roots
go deeper what Define what we want more
of yeah we all need to pay our rent
sometimes just making a damn decision
and committing to it is the best choice
not moving that indecisiveness between
two things
that limbo
you can walk that freaking tightrope
forever and you think it's going to last
a week and then it's a month and a year
and a freaking decade and then you're
looking up and you're going 15 years
later going
I haven't moved most things that I went
after
that headline I chased that decision I
rank that risk I took when I got there
the headline was not the same or I took
a feeder on the road but just the the
movement to make the choice to jump and
not fall to affirmatively take it
just gets things in motion again
without dreams we all will die
you've got to dream
don't lose your dreams
for yourself for your future for your
family the dreams of love and Enterprise
and travel and doing things becoming
something unique on your journey here
don't lose your dreams do some dreaming
that's long-range goals you've got to
have those
if you don't get busy and work on it
sure enough the time will pass and sure
enough five years from now you'll wind
up where you don't want to be where and
what you don't want to wear driving what
you don't want to drive being what you
don't want to be
now is the time to fix it
promise yourself you will never give up
don't just be listeners be doers the
world admires the doers whatever it
takes to get you to try harder read more
set your goals and go for it
the minute you were born it got risky
if you think prying is risky wait till
they hand you the bill for not trying
if you think investing is risky wait
till you get the tab for not investing
see it's all risky getting married is
risky having children is risky going
into business is risky investing your
money is risky it's all risky
[Music]
I'll tell you how risky life is you're
not going to get out alive
it's not important how long you live
what's important is how you live
[Music]
to the pessimists the glasses always
have
empty
to The Optimist the glasses half full
why would the same measure affect people
two different ways answer it all depends
on how you look at it
our lives are mostly affected by the way
we think things are
not the way they are
the way we think they are affects us
most
poor thinking habits keeps most people
poor
not poor working habits most people work
hard but they don't think hard the mind
is like a factory and whatever you think
about all day long pours ingredients
into this mental Factory and that's what
builds the economic social
Financial fabric of your life
[Music]
and you and I both know it's not the
amount of money in your pocket it's not
who you know it's not even what you've
been through
it's really the decisions you make
moment to moment since you look at
something think about something focus on
your side what does this mean
is this the beginning or the end
is this punishment reward
is God trying to hurt me or trying to
challenge me or is this nothing to do
with God I was just being a lazy bastard
right the meanings we give to things
control our life
whatever experience you're having right
now it has not come to stay
it has come to pass
not to stay just to pass it's just going
through
the biggest challenge is is to know
what's happening this is a part of this
thing we call life this too shall pass
and maintaining perspective putting it
in perspective
see a lot of us because of our limited
vision of ourselves a lot of us who
begin to focus on problems and enable
them to overwhelm us we begin to think
that we have no options we begin to
believe that there's no way out
say I'm unstoppable you've got to make
those kind of declarations to yourself
I'm unstoppable
do some things for you just go for a
stroll so you can engage in some
reflective thinking on life on yourself
looking and enjoying the universe
smelling the Roses along the way
listen to upbeat music music that
inspire you I have only but goodies I
have strategies that I engage in to
recharge my batteries I'm preparing for
that because I know things are going to
happen that I cannot anticipate very
good friend of mine died the other day I
had a program for myself I have books
that I read that inspire me tapes that I
listen to that fire me up because you're
going to have sometimes low moments when
you won't want to get out of bed
just want to stay there
at times you won't want to come out the
house the times you'll be feeling bad
and don't know why what's wrong I don't
know
just leave me alone
[Music]
take full responsibility for your life
accept where you are and the
responsibility that you're going to take
yourself where you want to go someone
said we have two primary choices in life
we can either accept conditions as they
exist or we can take the responsibility
to change them
see a lot of people want to exempt
themselves from taking responsibility
all they want to do is talk about the
problem every time you see them they'll
tell you their story over and over and
over and over again
no no you want to take responsibility
for your life I got me here I can get me
out of this
you're hitting on the Bedrock which is
extremely fundamental which is do you
believe that you're capable of change do
you believe that good things happen when
you go through a process of learning and
taking steps do you believe going back
to your belief that you could actually
get out of your patterns because you can
be fooling yourself you could be
you could be saying
yeah I kind of do but deep down inside
you don't really want to do it because
believe it or not your bad patterns give
you a degree of comfort right it's
something that you know and to get out
of them you suddenly thrust into the
unknown and that could be very
frightening so you could be holding on
to these bad patterns so the belief that
I can change I can actually do something
different in my life I can actually
recreate myself I can actually learn
things I can actually rewire my brain
because the brain is incredibly plastic
even at the age of 40 50 you can change
your career you can learn new skills you
know I've reached 60 I'm constantly
learning as well the brain is insanely
plastic do you believe that do you
believe that you have the possibility to
change yourself to alter your patterns
that's probably the single most
important thing right there and to get
people to believe that as I said there's
two levels there's the people who will
shake their head yeah yeah yeah they'll
read Mastery but it won't mean anything
to them because they're afraid of the
change they're comfortable with a degree
of failure I hate to say because if you
don't try things you never have to deal
with the response ability the pain of
failure right so you don't really want
to change deep down inside you don't
really believe how much more fun will
your life be if you're open and you let
things come in and new ideas come in so
it's up to you you're the one that's
creating your misery it's creating your
patterns
if you're going to win long term
95 of people have a operating system in
their mind where they operate out of
history and memory oh I like that and
about five percent of humans operate out
of vision and Imagination so the reason
we're so much happier I believe when
we're children is we have no history and
memory so we operate of imagination and
dreams and vision but at some age some
people it's five years old some it's
eight some it's 18 some it's 28. they
create a history and that history then
becomes the operating system so even if
they take on a new Behavior or tactic
they're operating out of a pattern of
thought and belief that's historic and
memory based and so the number one thing
I would say is begin to operate out of
your imagination again out of your
vision again create from that place if
you create from that place now you're
not tied to the result in that moment
you're giving yourself space to imagine
and create something new in your life
create a new future don't move away from
the past create a brilliant imaginative
curious vibrant vision for your life you
only understand the power
of one day when you're threatened with
never having another one
I'll do anything for one more day get to
be with you one more time the problem
with humanity is just this
that for every other creature Nature has
drawn two lines
Within These two lines they live and die
so their idea of full-fledged is hitting
the ceiling of their life
but if a human being hits a ceiling he
gets frustrated and miserable because
nature this process of evolution has
delivered to us to a place where there
is only the bottom line there is no Top
Line though some human beings are trying
to breach the bottom line and go below
nature determined a certain compulsive
instinctive ways of functioning
once you become human
these lines have been removed
you can act consciously that means what
you call as human potential is not of
any kind of measurable limit it can go
as far
as you desire or us as far as you have
the courage to walk
so when we say human potential
unleashing human potential
it is not about reaching the peak
it is a trajectory
because what our life is
is a combination of a certain amount of
time and energy
time is rolling away for all of us at
the same pace
if you sit it rolls away if you sleep it
rolls away if you do something it goes
away if you don't do anything it goes
away you're happy or miserable it goes
away
time is running out for all of us
so it's only the energy that you can
do different things with
if you bring your energies to a certain
level of intensity and possibility
[Music]
what somebody does in 10 years you may
do it in one year
this means if you live here for 100
years it feels like in people's impact
that you have created it feels like you
lived here for a thousand years simply
because you have managed your life
energies in a certain way
[Music]
have the power to make that decision
you can decide I'm going to work on
myself and develop myself I'm going to
empower me
and all of these things that are
happening to me right now they're just
temporary inconveniences they're not
stronger than I am
I'm in charge here
if you are a little sensitive to life
you will realize you are the biggest
issue in your life
[Music]
so this is one thing that I'm trying to
do with people that you are never the
issue in your life I'm not the issue my
thought my emotion my body is never the
issue
my thought my emotion my energy and my
body are my instruments a function they
are not impairments in my life but I
would say for 90 of the human beings
their own body then the compulsions of
the body the compulsions of their
thought the compulsions of their
emotions
or ruling them most of the time
so when you yourself are a problem
well your own self-help
everybody wants a solution but nobody
wants to delve into the problem and see
what is the nature of the problem that
we have
the nature of the problem is like this
why are we compulsive what is it that's
compulsive about us
compulsion means we are going to the
same place again and again that means
we're going in circles
the nature of physical existence in the
universe is such whether you take an
atom an individual atom or the cosmic
space
everything that's physical is always in
cyclical movement
the atoms are doing their circles the
solar system is doing its stuff the
galaxies are doing their stuff our own
bodies are going through Cycles in fact
we are born because of the Cycles in our
mother's bodies that's why we are born
so entire physical nature is born out of
cyclical movement that means
compulsiveness so do not misunderstand
compulsiveness as something bad it's the
basis of your existence
it is a good platform
but you're supposed to stand on the
platform and act
right now you have become the platform
so somebody else will dance on you there
is substantial medical and scientific
evidence to show that
only when you're in a pleasant state of
experience your body and your brain
works at its best there's no argument
about them there's enough evidence to
show that
so whatever impact or success or
reaching goals or growth or whatever you
say
on one level in the physical world it's
about how well you harness your
physiological and your psychological
process isn't it
whether your body and mind works against
you or works for you this is a big
difference
so there is even enough evidence to show
only when you're in Pleasant levels of
experience this happens best
so obviously Joy's first then growth if
you're joyful constantly and you have no
fear of suffering because you understand
all Human Experience comes from within
you and so you have managed to create
the kind of experience that you want now
growth is possible and brittled
if you have the fear of falling down and
suffering you will not go very high
isn't it
and no proof no one does that there's
going to be
life after this life but I'm not looking
forward to leaving this life but I'm
damn excited about what might happen
when it's time
it humbles me in a way that it gives me
great confidence
where it didn't used to
it used to Humble me in a way that maybe
I felt more lowly or my head would bow
down and my shoulders would slump
I believe it helps me try to the ought
to Aspire to more what I ought to be
more daily and be on that be on that
grind or when it's easy to to to enjoy
that downhill and go yes it doesn't have
to be or you don't have to break a split
all the time it it can be easy to see
the beauty and to and to to get a
reciprocal reaction from the world when
the world's in Reverb and is given back
what I'm giving out that's when I feel
when I'm not objectifying the world or
either or people is when I feel like I
am in closer living closer to God's
likeness I'm chasing an immortal Finish
Line with no proof that there is
an immortal Finish Line